Film Courage: Dan, if we were to delve into the mind of
most new writers whether they live in LA
or or they're living somewhere else, do
you think that they view a lot of their
work as a sample or a series of samples
or are they seeing it as the next big
thing that Wow
once it's discovered this thing is
taking LA and New York and London by
storm?
Daniel Calvisi, Author: Definitely London yeah not as many
scripts get bought as used to be so I
think it's imperative that they think of
it more as a writing sample of their
work yeah too many new writers are
thinking I'm gonna sell this for six
figures and I can live off that for the
next ten years you know and I'm gonna
sell a whole bunch more scripts in that
in in the meantime but they don't buy as
many scripts as they used to and it's a
really really competitive market
especially for newbies so I think it's
best if you think of it more as a
writing sample but yeah I do see a lot
of writers who are trying to write for
the market and they're trying to write
something that they think Hollywood will
buy because Hollywood makes a lot of
those types of movies but unfortunately
they're borrowing formulas and cliches
from those movies and that's not the
right thing to do on the page on the
page you still need to really impress
that reader and have something unique
bring something to the table
let's say I'm a new writer and I'm very
precious about something and I've
written and it's very close to my heart
it's very emotional
I've been able to get a chance to
present it and I've been told this is a
great sample and now I'm hurt I'm angry
my hopes are dashed okay where do I go
from here well if you've been told you
mean it you've been told it's a great
sample but it's rejected or your manager
says I'm gonna send this out as a great
sample to get you jobs let's suppose
they sent it out to get me jobs and then
we've been told this is a great sample
but this isn't gonna work and what else
do you have and let's let's start
getting more samples you're not ready
yet
you're right you your your this is not
the end all right here that you thought
it was well I mean first cross that
bridge when you get to it you know it
only takes one great script to get your
foot in the door and that's gonna happen
you're gonna get rejected way more often
than they're gonna say this is a great
script and I want to work with you so
you got to have a thick skin you have to
get used to that rejection and the name
of the game is to find that one champion
in the business for that particular
script that you have and four out of
five people are gonna pass on it nine
out of ten studios that you send it to
are gonna pass on it so it's your job to
find that one champion executive or
producer or agent that is willing to go
all the way with it that is willing to
push push past that rejection over and
over until the point where it does get
option or sold or made as a cheap movie
that's funded on Kickstarter by a really
talented director okay so then let's
suppose we keep sending it out and my
take is they just don't get it they
don't understand where I'm coming from
they don't believe in this material
Hollywood just wants to make these
things that no one really cares about
there's no heart and soul am I too
sensitive for the industry do I just
really need to be honest with myself
about the work I'm creating I think you
should take some time away put it in a
drawer metaphorically take some time
away from it do some thinking and it's
your job to keep writing so if you only
want to write this one script then yeah
you are in the wrong place you're in the
wrong business so you have to keep
writing and writing and producing
material hopefully you have at least one
other idea that you want to write that
hopefully is a little bit more
commercial but you just have to keep
writing and you have to keep pushing
past rejection and yeah it is tough and
it's dog-eat-dog so if you don't have
the thick skin for it then maybe it's
not the business for you well what if I
know that I'm
sensitive but I still want to be in the
industry I mean it's it's a realization
that you know we find out things about
ourselves we don't necessarily want to
be a certain way but what if we say okay
so I can't submit my own work because
I'm so precious about it and it makes me
so infuriated to know that I can't get
it made but what else can I do in the
industry where it's not as personal well
I think you just should produce it
yourself I think you should produce your
work like for example you can take your
feature and you could cut it up into
10-minute webisodes for example and put
it on YouTube put it on Vimeo and
produce something put something out into
the world rather than just keep getting
rejected and if you feel like you're too
sensitive to keep getting rejected well
at least at the end of the day you've
produced this and you have something you
know something of quality that you're
proud of and it could potentially get
either people to reconsider the script
or reconsider you as someone who could
who could potentially write an
assignment and what about other jobs
where there might be more of a steady
paycheck coming in well there's tons of
jobs in the industry if you want to go
into production you know start as a PA
they're jobs and development offices
there's jobs I see jobs listed all the
time on LinkedIn there's a lot of jobs
for social media coordinators at various
companies I see Netflix and Amazon and
even like commercial production
companies and a lot of companies
involved with entertainment so I mean I
don't know if I could say a specific job
for a sensitive writer what they would
do but I would say look on LinkedIn
there's actually a lot of jobs in the
entertainment industry
you